tue l'enfant prodigue de Denver de la
Voie Lactée
Nick Fury mon borgne préféré d'
Entrée comment ça se passe là-bas Je ne sais pas
froid Pas d'espace aérien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu m'as tout pris
et maintenant je rends le  favorise
[Musique]
ce qui m'arrive,
elle a empêtré nos pouvoirs basés sur la lumière
donc nous changeons de place chaque fois que nous les utilisons
forte Théorie,
tu peux absorber la lumière,
je peux la voir et Kamala qui est Kamala salut,
elle peut transformer la lumière en matière physique
qui  Je n'en ai jamais entendu parler Je pourrais
totalement vous montrer aucune
[Musique] [
Musique] étrangère Je
ne choisirais jamais d'impliquer qui que ce soit
dans tout ça,
vous n'êtes pas la seule chose qui se dresse
entre cela et l'univers [Musique]
équipe
[Musique]
plus vite
Je ne peux pas, peux-tu, je l'ai